-You have pulled off -- I don'
think people quite appreciat
the coup that you pulled off
with this show "Tommy"
because it is about
an L.A. police chief.
And yet it is filmed
in New York City.
-Yeah.
-Which is insane.
-Sometimes they will shoot
Vancouver and try to make that
look like New York
because it's
cheaper in Vancouver.
Nothing is more expensive
than New York City.
And yet, here they are
pretending
to make it look
like Los Angeles.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, for it to be a coup
I had to have some sort of
volition, I think.
-Yeah, that's true, yeah.
-'Cause I didn't with this
I read it, and I thought,
"Oh, this is so good,
but it's in L.A. Oh, well.
And that was the end of it
And then my agent
came back and said,
"Well, what if they shot i
in New York?"
I thought he was making a joke
But apparently he wasn't.
-Yeah.
-We have our palm trees
and we stick them
in front of each location.
-And it works.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, we've only had
one episode air so far.
Not a ton of comments.
-That's true.
-"That's not L.A."
We'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
-Have there been moments -
Obviously, there's different
weather patterns.
-Indeed.
-Yeah.
-Well, on my phone,
I have us shooting
exterior scenes in a squall.
Remember that night where
there was those crazy snowstorms
around November or something
That was insane,
really insane.
The poor guys would come out
and wipe all the cars down
"Roll camera, roll camera!
Anyway.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if it has legs.
-We'll see.
-We'll see. We shall see.
-How do you -- you have been -
You appeared in shows with
police before.
You've never played -- I believe
this is the first time you'v
played a police officer?
-Yes, it is, I guess.
I played an E.M.T.
and a prison warden.
I don't know.
I mean, they all carry thing
to hit people with.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you think you, in general,
would have made
a good police officer?
-I do. I do, actually.
It's an interesting question
I'm bossy.
-Yeah.
-I'm type-A. I like to tel
people what to do.
-That all sounds pretty much
right in the job description
-Pretty much, yeah.
-What about the uniform?
Do you enjoy that?
-Hideous.
I got to to say.
I mean,
I like the authenticity piece,
but the uniforms
are made out of
some plastic amalgamation,
something.
-Yeah.
-Horrible.
They're so uncomfortable.
And I mean, I have
a whole, new -- [ Laughs ]
That's what it takes for m
to have a respect for the cops
that they're able to wear
these things all day.
They're just horrible.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, a very unique
costume over years
you did was Carmela Soprano.
Did you find over time
that you enjoyed that style?
Did you go,
"I like Carmela's style"?
Or were you very happy
to say goodbye to it?
-Never happened. Not once.
-Yeah.
-Even at the end of
all the years of shooting,
they'll often say,
"Take a look at your wardrobe.
Do you want to take
any of it home?"
I was like, "No."
[ Laughter ]
-That is a clean break.
-This is good.
I need to really separate.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
It's always such a delight
to have you on the show.